c'est un nouveau tour de force accompli
par le zoo de Beauval malgré la baisse
du pouvoir d'achat des Français la barre
des 2 millions de visiteurs a donc été
atteintes l'an dernier encore absolu en
40 ans d'existence c'est une commune
Saint-Aignan et toute une région qui ont
bénéficié de l'envol du premier site
touristique de centre Val de Loire les
la Turquie avec clémencedosc
au départ petit parc pour oiseaux 42 ans
après le zoo de Beauval a bien grandi 44
hectares et maintenant 2 millions de
visiteurs c'est la destination
incontournable du Loir-et-Cher et l'un
des plus gros moteurs touristiques de la
région
c'est ça sera 1500 emplois directs cette
année en 2023 mais c'est plus de 3000
emplois aux alentours tout est chambres
d'hôtes et hégite tous les commerces
autour ils resteront Beauval génère une
vraie économie non déocaïssables sur un
territoire qui était pas forcément en
peine emploi une attractivité qui
profite à la ville de Saint-Aignan avant
l'ouverture du parc la commune comptait
deux restaurants on en dénombre
maintenant plus d'une vingtaine une
augmentation nécessaire mais toujours
insuffisante pour absorber le flux de
visiteurs à la sortie du zoo on a
effectivement l'effet de la fin de
journée au zoo la les gens ont plaisir à
redescendre en centre-ville de
Saint-Aignan pour une balade en des
villes évidemment pour se restaurer il
nous arrive effectivement d'avoir des
soirées ou tout est complet alentours
sur une vingtaine ou une trentaine de
kilomètres autour de Saint-Aignan
Beauval continue sur sa lancée après le
dôme équatorial c'est une nouvelle
volière qui devrait voir le jour en 2023
accompagné d'un hôtel au cœur de
Saint-Aignan ce seront alors 2000
proposés par Beauval parmi les 13000 que
compte la vallée du Cher